mount etna is the largest volcano in
Europe right now it's active again
someone who is well acquainted with Edna
is Ranger Luca ferlito every day for
leto drives through the ash and lava
fields to help lost tourists he'll also
be the first on the scene if Edna erupts
rondo Oahu tomado when I first got the
chance to work on the volcano and feel
it breathe it nearly pulled me over hey
when I cause I gave me a place hotel
meant it of course I really respect
volcano yone un gran de respeto per
questa per questo volcano all his life
ferlito has been fascinated by Aetna's
landscape his family comes from this
region of Sicily de pico la veo painadu
Annie yo Padre when I was still little
when I was just too Johnny my father
took me there on an excursion best image
of the volcano erupting that shape of my
life la veta during Aetna's last major
eruption in 1669 streams of lava flooded
into nearby Catania today you can still
see what it was like in the basement of
the city's University
t3 amo internodal we're here inside
Catania's Benedictine monastery only
today the monastery is a university here
you see what was then the monasteries
kitchen it was built on the lava that
flowed down from aetna in 1669 a lot of
the monastery and its surrounding fields
were destroyed then I intorno the
eruption nearly destroyed the city but
it left behind the materials for
rebuilding it as well today streets
houses and even the city's emblem an
elephant are made from lava stone nearby
you can even find out what Edna tastes
like in modica people have always made
chocolate using the stone 80 year old
Luigi buddy Eddie is the last maestro of
this local tradition a single men java
first you heated the chocolate and after
it melted you stirred it and then you
poured it on to the stone these days
machines have largely replaced lava
stone the local specialty is chocolate
made with cocoa sugar vanilla and
cinnamon it's cooked at only 45 degrees
so it has an intense flavor the local
wine is also famed for its intense taste
many vineyards here are nestled on the
slopes of Etna the cambria family owns
one of them let Benassi what I mean
montes now makes this region a unique
special wine-growing area it's really
what gives the whole region its
character torito unique or particle are
especially davay avenia Nomo here the
wines have a very distinct character
they're fresh because of the altitude of
which they're grown and the mineral-rich
soil makes the volcanic wines very
strong tasting ec a warning ship
mariangela Cambria says her family has
been running the cotton era vineyard
since 1970 she's part of the second
generation the winery employs 25 people
and produces whines like narela Maskull
easy and Merlot but maybe no significant
wine is about land passion and love
it's not just a red liquid that you pour
in a glass it's also a history of the
people who believed in the properties of
the region soil and still do continue on
occurred after the Sun sets on aetna
Giovanni trim bullies day begins his
wine store offers Sicilian food with a
twist this food is prepared with local
wines whether it entity beginner did
adamo one of the typical dishes we
prepare is cauliflower marinated in red
wine yella talk I will sort of forgotten
and then and we not awesome cuz we
prepared carefully then cook it and then
serve it with another Edna red wine
because the wines fragrance and taste is
unique it can't be compared to any other
one on earth vivo de vino for Sicilians
aetna isn't just Europe's biggest
volcano the mountain shapes almost
everyone's life here